-I want to show another --
Yeah, you were posting
a lot of old photos.
This is you
and that's Simon Rich
and that's Marika Sawyer.
And the three of you wrote
together and dear friends.
-Yes, we wrote
about three sketches together
every week for three years.
We were the closest of friends.
And, uh, we would all sit --
The three of us would sit
in a room
writing filthy sketches
all night long.
And you would kind of check in
and be like,
"What are you guys doing?"
-Yeah.
-And you'd get a piece of it
and be like,
"No, I don't like it."
[ Laughter ]
And, uh, so we were doing
a Thanksgiving scene,
and we thought,
"Let's take a picture,
and we'll make a Thanksgiving
card for Seth.
And, uh, we'll give it to him."
So, that was the photo we took,
and, uh, we made a card,
and it had this on the front.
It said,
"Happy Thanksgiving, Seth."
And then, when you opened it,
it said,
"We [bleep] each other."
[ Laughter ]
And...then we signed it.
It was nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was nice.
-Yeah.
-Um, we -- Another "SNL" sketch
you were in
is a writer we both love
wrote --
This is "Drag Brunch."
-Thrill of a lifetime. Yes.
-James Anderson --
How would you describe
James Anderson,
for those who aren't
lucky enough to know him?
-Don't be distracted
by this photo.
James Anderson is the writer
who wrote this sketch,
"Drag Brunch," and is the
funniest person in the world
and that any of us
have ever worked with.
-Absolutely consistently funny,
week after week.
And he's been working at "SNL"
since, I think, 2000.
-Yes. And would come
into the rewrite room
not knowing
what anyone was pitching on
and pitch a joke that would
work better than anything.
He would walk in and say like,
"Why doesn't she just go,
'I want a Purpsi'?"
And we'd be like, "All right.
We'll put that in."
So, just, like, funny bones,
funny bones.
And, uh, he wrote a sketch
called "Drag Brunch,"
and I said to him,
"It is the thrill of my life
to be in a sketch
that you wrote."
-And it was fantastic.
-And I got
to wear heels on concrete,
which is fun.
-Did it -- Did you --
Do your shins still hurt
from wearing --
-No, we figured it out good.
Uh, me and the wonderful
costume department --
You know, we judged based --
I have a tear in my hip, too,
so we were factoring that in.
-Got it.
-How high the heels could be.
Walking on concrete,
never having done it before.
Super nervous.
All those things went in.
We went with a low heel.
-Oh, wow.
Do you have
a greater appreciation
for those in drag
for how hard it was?
-Um, I have a greater
appreciation for those shoes
and for all the times
I've been like,
"Come on! Let's get the cab!"
You know?
-Yeah.
-Come on! The Uber's here!
-[ Laughs ]
-I like --
Watch me walk in real time.
It's like -- It was like...
when a -- when a cow's born.
[ Laughter ]
A calf, I guess you'd say.
-They're called calves.
-They're called calves at first.
-This is a sketch you wrote.
You and Colin Jost
wrote this years ago.
-Yeah. And you didn't pick it.
-Uh...
I --
-You were the head of writing.
-I was the head of writing,
but I thought --
I remember saying, like --
I'm like, "Save it
for when he comes back."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'll wait
till one of these writers
improbably hosts."
-You were a "Les Mis" fan
as a child.
So this -- I should point out,
this sketch was called
"Diner Lobster."
-Yes.
-And it was to
the "Les Mis" soundtrack.
-Yes, it was about
a diner that serves lobster,
as some in New York do.
Someone finally
orders the lobster,
and we bring out the lobster,
who's Kenan playing
a Jean Valjean type.
He's facing death.
He's lived in the diner
for 40 years,
and the only music to accompany
that is "Les Miserables."
So what we did was we wrote it
by listening
to the "Les Mis" soundtrack,
and then we changed
the words of the songs
and we made them
about being a lobster.
[ Laughter ]
-And that's sketch writing.
-And that was at the table
in 2010.
-Yeah.
-And I remember it was done.
And it wasn't like you were mad,
but everyone was just like,
"Guys."
[ Laughter ]
And then we moved on.
And now it's on TV.
-Who'd you write it for?
Do you remember who
you originally wrote it for?
-Um, I think Galifianakis
was the host.
-Oh, all right.
-Yeah.
-Well, I think you elevated it.
[ Laughter ]
There's a person on TV
you get mistaken for.
-Yes.
-And you got mistaken
in the park the other day?
-No, this has been
happening a lot.
I'm not saying
I look like The Flash, but...
-Oh!
-I've been told enough --
-Somebody just went "Oh"
like they kind of see it.
-Oh.
They're like --
Now they think I'm The Flash.
But it's happened enough
that I need to say something.
I'm not The Flash.
[ Laughter ]
I was at the dog park.
I had my dog. Don't worry.
[ Laughter ]
and I see this woman --
older woman and a little boy
are walking along
the gate of the dog park,
and the boy is jumping up
to look over the gate.
And he's jumping up and he goes,
"Flash. Flash. Flash."
Like he had a little accent from
like, old Europe when old --
like old spelled with an E,
you know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Like, "Flash, Flash!"
And his companion, grandmother,
whatever, she goes,
"He says you are The Flash."
And I said,
"No, I'm not The Flash."
You know, and he keeps going,
"Flash, Flash."
And she goes, "Are you sure
you're not The Flash?"
And I said, "It happens
from time to time.
I'm not The Flash."
Right at that second, someone
walked up who recognized me
from stand-up comedy and said,
"Hey, I'm a big fan."
And I went,
"Thank you very much."
And they walked away.
[ Laughter ]
And then I locked eyes with the
grandmother and she was so mad.
And she looked at me
and she said,
"No, you are not The Flash."
[ Laughter ]
-Just for those who don't know,
let's go over to camera one.
There's the Flash.
-Yeah, it's not --
It's not perfect.
-It's not bad, though.
-When I came home -- I came back
to the apartment,
I was like,
"I'm sick of being The Flash!"
I gave no context to my wife,
no context.
[ Laughter ]
I go, "This kid thinks
I was The Flash.
And the grandma's mad at me.
and then, this guy said
he was a big fan of mine,
and that was embarrassing."
And my wife, Anna, was like,
"So, let me get this straight.
Your two problems are that
a fan said he likes your work
and that people think you look
like a 25-year-old,
handsome actor who, by the way,
you don't look like."
[ Laughter ]